so I returned after all all that to my
original subject how to change the world
my answer is by becoming subjective part
of the consequences of a local event
becoming a subjective part of the
consequences of local event at the
different level to fall in love can be
change the world but it precisely to
become a subjective part of the
consequences of a local event by
creation of an equivalence between
freedom and discipline not an opposition
but the point where to be obstinate
to do something is the same thing as a
freedom and the invention by the
invention of a new form of happiness
which is a victory against the potency
of death that is repperton say of the
patient to stay in your place at a very
important moment of the French
Revolution the great French Revolution
one of the great actors and thinkers of
this political swing sequence scientists
a said happiness is a new ID in Europa
happiness is a new idea in Europe
maybe we must create the condition to
say the same thing we know that
something is changing in a world when we
experiment that happiness is not the
predetermine a goal of the movement but
the inventive subjective ization of the
movement itself it has been in fact a
fundamental idea of Marx for Mark's the
name of the new possibility of
collective justice after some revolution
some advance in 1848 and so on in the
middle of the nineteenth century for
among the name of the new possibility of
corrective justice was as you know
communism but Marx as written it was
younger in the manuscripts of 1844
communism is not the program of a new
society or an abstract idea of justice
communism is the name of the historical
process of destruction of the old
society so you see the challenge is not
to achieve a result the result lies
inside the change itself of the form in
the form of the new subject maybe we can
say happiness is not the general
possibility of satisfaction happiness is
not the abstract ID of
good society where everybody is
satisfied happiness is objectivity of a
difficult task to organize the
consequences of some event and to
discover under the sod existence of a
world the brilliant
possibilities of the Eden real of the
world finally we can say to enjoy
finally the poor full creative existence
of what was from the point of view of
the world impossible the powerful
creative existence of the impossible as
such when we discover the possibility of
this impossibility so how to change the
world the answer is a nice one by being
a pain not as a result of the change but
by the change itself but we must pay
surprise surprise is to be sometimes in
satisfied it's a choice that will choice
between happiness and satisfaction and
it is the choice of what we can name the
tool life maybe through the world of
today are many defaults but the most
important thing is that the world of
today's will propose a false life life
which is the seeming of life and so
to do the choice of happiness against
satisfaction and local experiences
artistic creation political invention
and so on and to be in the new freedom
has a disciplined it'll choice against
taxation in some extent so we are
exposed to the possibility to be
sometimes in satisfied in the name of a
penis it's a cries Enterprise the French
poet after Rambo as written the true
life is not here the true life is absent
I just say to you after or you can
decide that the true life is here that
little life is not absent choose the new
apenas and pay the price
thank you